- I say put mental health first,
because if you don't, then
you're not gonna enjoy your sport
and you're not gonna succeed
as much as you want to.
So it's okay sometimes to even sit out
of the big competitions
to focus on yourself,
because it shows how
strong of a competitor
and person that you really are
rather than just battle through it.
(upbeat music)
- [Jason] We've seen
increasingly that athletes
are getting comfortable with the idea
of discussing mental health
and the idea of treating
their state of mind,
and mental health as kind of a body part
in the same way they would
attend to a sprained ankle
or a pulled hamstring
that they are gonna take time to recover
if they're feeling any
kind of mental duress.
And I think it's a really healthy
and productive conversation to have.
Teams and franchises
and athletes and coaches
now treat physical injury different
than they did a generation ago.
The idea of like, just icing somebody down
or like slapping them
upside the head and saying,
get back out there and do it for the team
is increasingly a fading notion.
And mental health is sort of
a new part of the prism here.
The idea that teams
would have an investment
and not just the mental health
that applies to their
execution on the playing field,
but just their general health
and happiness is a new thing.
And I think that it actually in this case
an interesting way has
been athlete driven.
It's the athletes who are coming forward
and talking with great candor
about their own struggles.
- And I think we're just a
little bit too stressed out,
but we should be out here having fun
and sometimes that's not the case.
- In the past we know that
people have not talked
about mental health,
especially in the public realm
because there's so much
stigma that exists.
And while that stigma still exists,
we see a lot of high profile athletes
talking about their mental health.
On the clinical side,
we also see a lot more cooperation
with larger organizations
to try and understand
what it means to have a
mental health diagnosis
and what that might look like
for their individual athletes.
A lot of people think
that athletes just appear
and show us their natural
grace and abilities.
And while it's true,
many of them have outstanding
physical abilities
and we love watching them perform,
it takes many, many hours
to get them in that
place of mental toughness
to be able to execute
their skills on demand.
So I think that it's important
for people to understand
that even though they see
that public excellence,
sometimes there's quite
a bit of private anguish.
It's important for people to realize that
these athletes are humans
first, they have emotions,
they have lives outside of sport.
So it's important for them to
take care of themselves too.
- [Jason] We've already seen
in the conversation that's happening
and the elevation of the
topic, not just in sports,
but in, workplaces at large,
a real benefit for people to feel
that they can have the
liberty and the courage
to come forward and have
these kinds of conversations.
That kind of comfort, I think
is a real important thing.
And we've seen it in the past
that sports can often be a vessel
for broader societal conversations
and I think that's what's happening here.
(upbeat music)